[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Happy Thursday, everybody.
Welcome back to the
Data Science Hangout.
If this is your first time
joining us here today,
it is very nice to meet you.
And thanks for spending
your Thursday with us.
If we haven't met, I'm Rachael.
I host the Data Science
Hangout, of course,
and also lead customer
marketing at Posit.
This is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across
different industries.
So we're here every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So if you're watching
this recording on YouTube later,
the link to add it to your
calendar and join us live here
will be in the details below.
I also put a link in the chat,
just a little short link,
if you ever want to share
the hangout with friends too.
But together we're all
dedicated to making this a
welcoming environment
for everyone.
And we love to hear from
everybody no matter your years
of experience,
titles, industry,
or even languages
that you work in.
And so every week
at the hangout,
I'm joined by a
different leader from the community,
who joins us to share their
experience and answer questions from you all.
So if you're here
for the first time,
let me just give you a little
rundown of how this works.
It is totally OK to
just listen in here.
But there's also three ways that
you can jump in and ask
questions or provide your own
perspective on certain topics too.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom. And I'll
monitor that. You can put
questions in the Zoom chat.
And just put a little star next
to it if it's something you
want me to read out loud
instead if you're maybe in a
coffee shop or something.
And then, third, we
have a Slido link,
which Hannah just shared
when I said that, thank you,
where you can ask questions
anonymously as well.
With all that,
thank you so much for joining
us here this Thursday.
I'm so excited to be
joined by my co-host,
Ari Siggaard Knoph,
international lead programmer,
a statistical programming
specialist at Novo Nordisk. And,
Ari, I would love to have
you introduce yourself and
maybe pronounce your name
better than I did
and share a little bit about
the work that you do but
also something you like to do
outside of work too.
- Definitely, I think
you did it pretty well.
We used to say "Ki-noff"
as my last name. But
that's probably because we're in Scandinavia.
Yeah, she said I'm an
international lead programmer
at Novo Nordisk. And
that means that I'm like
the responsible programmer for all
of our programming deliverables
on clinical trials.
I'm responsible for
writing up documents for
the authorities and interact with
them whenever we have
interactions and,
in the end, the
primary responsible for our data
packages and code that
goes to authorities.
And,
yeah, outside of work,
I really love spending
time with my wife and kids.
I have two sons,
friends and family as well.
My oldest son recently
picked up golfing. And he's only
5 and 1/2. But I used to
play when I was younger.
And so we've been spending a lot
of good time on the range already.
And
I really like to play a lot
of guitar as well. So, yeah, that's
primarily what my
time goes with.
- That's awesome. Well,
thank you. It sounds like
your son's going
to be a superstar.
He's already starting at five.
- We'll see. We'll
see. He loves it.
So that's the most
important thing, yeah.
- That's great.
Well,
I get to start off with
the questions here as we wait for
everybody to start jumping in.
But I know in a few weeks,
you're going to give a
presentation here at Posit 2.
And you've reached
an incredible NDA milestone.
Could you explain a little bit
about what that means and what
you're going to be talking
about in a few weeks?
- Yeah. So, I mean, what's
really special about this is,
like in the past few
years, whenever we've been at conferences,
we've heard so much more about
our emerging within pharma. And people are
starting to use it more
in these GxP controlled environments.
And we've been working towards
setting up a GxP
approved environment and really--
- I'm sorry.
I use an acronym at first
because I forgot as I was
saying it what the actual
length was. But if we use
acronyms, do you mind just
explaining what they are too?
- Of course.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
OK, cool, thank you.
- Yeah, yeah, somebody wrote in the
chat. So NDA is a New Drug Application
to
the American authorities.
FDA, Food and Drug--
I mean, it's
very hard in pharma
because there are so many
abbreviations. So
it's very hard to
continue talking about subject
without mentioning some of
them. But I'll do
my best to speak.
- We'll try and do
it in the chat too.
It looks like Mike's ready to hang
out with and put acronyms in there.
- Yeah.
So what's really is special
about this milestone is,
yes, we have primarily used
proprietary language to do most
of our programming
within pharma.
And in recent years, people have been
opening much more up to
using open source languages.
But that comes with a lot
of challenges when you need to use
it in a heavily regulated
environment, such as pharma,
because there are
a lot of rules and spend
that you need to squeeze
down on top of your processes
in order to comply with
all
the regulatory authorities,
not only in the US
but around the world.
So a lot of demands to how
we actually produce code and
submit code and
data to authorities.
So we've been
working on it for--
we started
almost seven years
ago just trying
to do something with R.
And that has really
grown into now having
an NDA submission where we have
tables, figures, and
listings. Then in R,
we have some analysis
data sets then in R.
We have packages we have
submitted and so on. So
really the full Monty of doing this.
And the reason why
it's so special is--
like the number one question,
at least I've heard,
when we've been at conferences is
whether anybody has done it before.
And
the predecessor to what we've
done is really the work from
the ARC Consortium
working group.
There is one for
ARPA submission where
FDA also has played a huge
role in giving input to what's
possible with submitting this
in packages and our
code to the authority.
So
for us, it's really special that
at least now we have an
answer that we know
that we have done it.
And hopefully others will do
it soon in the future as well.
- That's great. And I was
putting my clapping emoji in
here. But thank you for sharing
that story in a few weeks too.
So I know when you are sharing a
little bit about what you do outside of work,
you mentioned that you're a
musician and play guitar as
well. And I see Libby called
this out in the chat too.
But we have so many
different musicians in the data space,
especially in this hangout room here. And
I was wondering like, how has that
carried over for you
into your day to work?
Or do you think that
it plays a part?
- I think, I mean--
so I'm a self-taught
musician. So
I learned it off
of YouTube, like
when YouTube was like
brand new almost.
I spent so much time learning
stuff off of YouTube.
And it's actually the same
with most of my R skills today.
I mean, I studied mathematics
at the university.
But it was like the
chalk and chalkboard type of mathematics.
We weren't doing that
much programming until the end.
So
I think a lot of the skills
that I've learned today,
especially around
art, comes from
both what the community is
putting out there in terms of
just like educational material.
But there are so many people putting
stuff up on YouTube to learn from.
And then there's also--
I mean, when you play
music with people,
you're kind of in
sync with them. And
not to make like
a cheesy analogy--
but, I, mean when you're
developing code with people,
I remember seeing this
almost a meme right about a
git commit history looking
like a Guitar
Hero track
because there's just so
many branching and so on.
So
I think there is
some great opportunities
to co-create
stuff with people both in
music and in code, yeah.
- That's great.
How do you actually collaborate
with your colleagues and code?
- So
it's not that long ago that
we, at least where I work,
moved into using version
control for most of what we do.
Even though we've been doing statistics
and programming for quite a while,
moving an entire organization into
learning Git and working with repository,
it's been quite
a challenge. But
I think we've been
quite successful in
lowering the barrier--
so wrapping a lot of stuff up
into other functions such that
you don't need to think about
how to set up a repo.
So we primarily use Azure DevOps
for how to set up a
repo, how to set up a pipeline.
How do I make sure that I have
the upstream set?
And how do I--
so all these things,
you're more--
I mean, people can--
it's very easy to get your
head around like commit, push, pull,
like those three commands.
Everything like outside of that
is a little bit more advanced.
So we use that here. And
then externally, I mean, now I'm also
levering more with people
through pharmaverse,
where we use GitHub and
also Git repositories for that, yeah.
- Awesome, I see Jeff.
I think you had a
follow-up question on this.
Do you want to jump in here?
I think the question is,
how do you do DevOps
with GitHub actions
and Docker?
And, Jeff,
feel free to jump in if
you want to add more context.
Are you just chiming in?
- So, I mean,
when we were testing out for
which product to use,
we first tested out GitLab.
But we found we had
much more freedom in
Azure DevOps also because
we wanted to try and do
some of our project
organization a little bit
differently like the way we organize
programs and who should do it and
how are we discussing about these things.
And GitHub don't have to
the same extent this project
organizations. They
do have Kanban boards.
But they don't have
the same level of
interactivity with work items and what
you can do in terms of
manipulating them with
pipelines and APIs and so on.
And also, I mean,
Novo is a major
customer at Microsoft.
So it was kind of right down
our ballpark to go to that product.
So we don't use
GitHub actions, unfortunately. We use
Azure DevOps and write a lot
of YAML files with pipelines
and bash scripting and so on.
- Yeah.
I was thinking maybe
in the beginning here,
it would be helpful for some of
us who don't come from a pharma
background to just understand
a little bit more about a
specific use case. Or walk
us through a project that your
team might work on.
- Yeah. So
I sit in the biostatistics
department. So that's really like the
evidence generating
department of
the drug development cycle. So
we help run clinical trials.
So we
have the--
people in the chain right
before us is like data
management. They
set up all the systems
to collect data.
And then we get the
data in biostatistics.
And not too long ago,
a lot of standards,
data standards, were rolled out
called the CDISC. And
I'm sorry. I can't really--
it's a very long acronym
for something [INAUDIBLE].
- That's OK.
- Yeah, but it's a
data standard for
collected data
and analysis data.
And we create these
data sets. It could
be based off lab data.
It could be like vital signs
data. It could be some specific
measurements, depending
on the disease area
that you're working in.
And this is where we
use R. We use SAS
for it as well.
We run the trials
in Git repos.
And
on top of this,
what we're trying to do now is
build tables and figures with R
but also
now Shiny applications on top
of that. Some of the first
selling points for
us to really get
R into the organization was
creating Shiny apps.
So we had
a very tedious process of
reviewing pharmacokinetic data,
where people were like
entering meetings with a
100-pager PDF document with
like pharmacokinetic curves. And
they had all reviewed them
before the meeting
with comments.
And then you would go
through everything.
And you had modeling outputs.
And it just seemed like such
an obvious use case for us to
go into a Shiny app. And
that was one of the first
thing that we really
sell to our stakeholders.
And so we
partially do that.
But our bread and butter
is creating these data sets.
It's doing statistical
analysis. It's doing
summary statistics, descriptive
statistics of adverse events,
like lab results and so on.
And then at the end, we
wrap all of these things up
into a submission
dossier, where
we have a medical writers who
write up documents, send it to
authorities. And now
there are at least three
health authorities around the world
who require that we send
our data and our code
to produce both the data
and tables and figures.
- Cool. Thank you. So did
you basically say to them, hey,
you don't have to go through
this 100-page document, here's the SAP?
- Yeah, yeah. I
mean, basically so.
When you always
have a project--
when you have a
project like that,
you always like
tend to maybe go--
you want to do too much
in the beginning. You want to automate.
We want to have automatic
minutes based off like the
comments that
people were doing.
And, essentially--
yeah, I mean, in the
beginning, it was just like,
you don't have to
look at it in PDF.
We're also [INAUDIBLE]
here. And
you can look at
it in the screen.
And then we'll build out
the modules around communicating in
the app, seeing what other
people have done, and so on.
- Cool. Thank you. Travis,
I see you had a question
in the chat a bit earlier.
You want to jump in?
- Sure.
So Nova's been working on
this open study builder solution,
which is more focused on data
capture. For those not in
pharma, it'd be like
electronic data capture.
So EDC systems is the
front end that faces
clinicians or their research
assistants or whomever is
entering data. And
these are dominated by
a couple of giant and--
I'll just say like--
let's say, legacy looking
software providers.
And so this open study builder
looks really interesting.
But it's very much kind of Neo4j and
kind of in the weeds on that side.
Wondering what the connection to
your side of the house looks
like on the biostats side.
Are they plugging it into R?
Or do you have good APIs? Or
is that kind of future state?
- Yeah. So
just to give a little
bit of history to that.
So we have had a
system for metadata management for quite
some years. So whenever
we start up a trial,
we build the entire trial
design with all of the lab
parameters and all [INAUDIBLE]
and so on.
And that really builds
like a metadata infrastructure for
when we need to run the trials.
And we also put in
metadata to use in
the actual outputs--
tables and figures and
so on. And we found
that works really well
when you're just developing our
small part in biostatistics. But what
we really want to do is--
let's say I have made a
data about some parameter
definition. And
they're writing up a protocol
where they want to
use that parameter.
The open study builder
will kind of be
the one
source of truth for everything
that's kind of connected to
data in some way or another.
And that's why they also build it
on top of this graph technology from
Neo4j.
So what we will use it for is,
like, writing protocols,
where you have topic-based
text that you just pull out.
It's to build a much
more coherent and metadata driven
full pipeline around the
biostatistics and the
deliverables we do.
So we've been using
metadata for many years.
But
we want to reuse a lot
of that information in the documents
that we write such that--
because a lot of projects today
are kind of making up their--
not making up their
own. But they're
slightly changing up the
definition of things when they
write it in protocols
or data reviewer's guide or
whatever it is that we're
handing over to authorities. So
it's to build a system
to manage all of that.
And for us, yeah, it will be
API calls internally. We have--
like the same way we have
a master model of our metadata,
for instance, STDM,
study data and analysis data.
We also have a master model
of all the metadata data sets
that go into producing both
those data sets but also
tables, figures,
and listings. So
we're betting
really hard on having
a fully metadata driven
pipeline to
the extent possible
that we can do it.
- Thank you.
I'm going to jump over to a few
of the anonymous questions too. And one was,
could Ari share a bit about
how he got into the pharma industry?
- Yeah. So as I said, my
background was in mathematics.
I was doing a topology and
high dimensional geometry.
And at some point,
during the masters part of
my education, I was thinking like,
who needs this out
in the real world?
So I kind of shifted
towards doing more like statistics
stuff, doing more programming.
And I kind of learned that high
dimensional geometry is not
that different from
n dimensional feature spaces. And
I got really caught up in
learning about
machine learning then.
And I did my master's thesis in
prediction modeling
on MRI data.
So I was really intrigued by
that intersection
between medicine
and
technology. What could
you do in that field?
So I was looking for
places where I could explore
that more. At that time,
Siemens were the one creating
all the MRI machines.
I don't think there's Siemens
here in Denmark, where I live.
And I ended up applying for
a job at Novo at that time.
And
so I started here straight
out of university and
haven't left
since, I would say.
- That's great. Thank you.
OK, let's see.
I'll jump over to--
Mike, I saw you asked a
question earlier in the chat.
You want to jump in here next?
- Need to remind myself
what the question was. Apologies.
So I saw a really interesting
presentation from
Novo Nordisk about--
there's
essentially a pharmaverse of
R packages that you're using.
And you have packages
for everything basically,
which is amazing.
So
are those packages
developed like from--
not from scratch within Novo?
Or are those kind of Novo
wrappers around other things?
- So
they are primarily
wrappers around
tidyverse stuff
because there are internal
standards to pretty much
anything you could think of
that there is a standard for.
And some of them are to
make it possible to work with
R within our environment,
like the way we store data,
the way we export things,
and I said like utility
functions to work with Azure
DevOps, to work with
Git, to work with
to all these different systems
that we have internally.
And some of them--
can you still
hear me all right?
- Yes.
I think it froze for
a second on my end.
But I could hear
you the whole time.
- OK.
So some of it
is like layering on top of
these metadata to do things smarter.
Some of it is
building like a package for
creating tables that are
specific to the Novo way
of styling tables and so on.
But one thing that kind of is--
kind of catch up to us is
they were developed without
looking too much to the open
source world. So now when we
actually want to do more with
pharmaverse, where multiple
companies are working,
it's really hard to
separate like the Novo part
and like the real
functionality of the package.
So we're working on that now.
- It's an interesting
design issue then because
I can understand that building
wrappers on existing things to
tailor it for your needs is
a really neat way of doing things.
But as you say,
it kind of then locks you
into a particular way of working
that maybe has
problems down the line.
So there are probably
pros and cons, right?
- Exactly.
And we do--
and I mean, there's also--
in recent years,
so many companies have opened up
much more to talk about how
they're actually
solving things.
And we're also
doing that as well.
And we really want to
contribute to kind of keeping
those lines open. So we
are definitely trying to
pivot some of our
packages, either
kind of committing to some
of the open source packages that
are there or pivoting our
packages and see if they can
get into the open source well.
- Amanda, I see you
raised your hand.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Hi, yeah. So I'm a
little bit curious about the transition
Novo Nordisk made.
I guess there's two parts
to this question. The first is,
during that trying to prove
that the pharmaverse are using
R was just as good
as SAS programming,
did you have--
I know there's always a
second reader on the data.
So did you have one person
using R and the other person
using SAS? Or how did that go?
And then the other
question I have is--
I've seen some reports of the
R and SAS data coming back just
slightly different,
nothing that would change a
decision or anything but just
slightly different.
So how do you sort of address
that as you're sort of mid
transition here?
- I mean, to speak to
your first question, so
our primary
goal has not been to replace
SAS with R. I mean, we are
really aiming for a much more
language agnostic world,
where programmers use the
language that they're most
comfortable with.
In terms of getting
it into the organization
and having people using it,
we started out--
what we really wanted to prove
was that it was possible to
make a real deliverable with R,
where we made the tables and
figures in R.
So there we did the actual
deliverable in R. And we did the
parallel programming and
stuff to make sure that
it is that as what we would
expect to get in SAS as well.
And then down the line,
I mean, I remember seeing
one of my good peers,
Michael Rimler from
GSK talking about their
program called R
for validation,
where they were rolling out that
everybody was allowed to use R for
core validation.
And
I think
building on top of that,
we thought that, well, I mean,
they're already using
it for validation.
So why not try to use it
in production, like on a very small scale?
And now today we have
all kinds of
mixtures of how people
are approaching it.
Whether they're doing the
primary program in SAS and R
is not that important anymore because
we kind of built up an
environment that supports
a multilingual execution.
And now I can't remember
your second question.
Can you repeat that again?
- Mostly about how--
because there are small
differences in the numerical output,
how is that addressed?
- Yeah. So
I mean--
so we expect that
there is a difference.
And in many of the
compare packages
that's out there, you
can set a criterion on how
to which decimal places
should the numbers align.
And there's always like--
when you're storing
floating point integers,
there will always be like
a small difference even with
the same number within
the same system.
And I think what we
have really been preaching internally is
that we really try to
preach conclusions
over numbers.
So, of course, if you see
something that's totally off,
you're going to investigate
what's happened there. But
when we use and set these
two systems up against each other,
are we still looking at
the same conclusions for
these
adverse events or this
lab parameter and so on?
So that's been our take on it.
- Thank you.
Jared, I see you had
asked a question.
One had a star. So maybe
I'll start reading.
And if you want to jump in,
I'll look to see if you unmute.
But Jared said,
definitely interested in knowing
more about how you pitched
to your upper management to
use Shiny apps. And Jared said,
mainly I get pushback because
of validation concerns
on doing that versus the
standard 200-page PDF files.
- Yeah.
I think
I would say, luckily,
our management have
been very open to--
it's almost expected that you try
and solve problems in a new
way. And that's kind
of what we've been
raised with here, at least
I've been raised with it here.
So,
of course, there are a
lot of technical aspects around that.
But we kind of did
the same thing that you
would do with maybe another
innovation product is that you
would talk with the people who
are supposed to use it. And
most of them said that it
was a really good idea.
And then we said
to our managers,
everybody thinks this
is a great idea, right?
And we think we have the
skills to build it. And, of course,
one good thing is it's always
good to apply a little bit of
action on an idea before you
go searching for opinions
because opinions can quickly
hold you back.
And we had already
applied some actions,
like built something around it.
And so you're kind of coming
up with something that they almost--
at least we're trying to
get into a scenario where they
can't say no or at least that--
like, can we test this
out on one or two trials?
And then you make sure that
all of the downstream
processes around this--
I mean, we're still
in compliance with
standards. We're still able
to deliver everything
we're supposed to do.
And
now, hopefully, people will be
a lot happier. And now also,
like CO2--
we really want to save
some trees as well.
So that's been a major
selling point for us
in terms of Shiny apps.
And then also,
another thing that I think most
companies say today is that
they really want to be data-driven.
And if you want to hold people
to their word, I think--
our community is
probably one of the
parts of the organization that
have the most enabling power to
give to other people who
doesn't necessarily have data
scientist skills.
And I think that's--
if you can make somebody--
a higher up in the organization
realize that you can make so
many people do their job in a
much more simple way just by going
into a Shiny app or maybe
even just like looking at automated
reports on a [INAUDIBLE],
what be it, that you can
enable so many people
just by doing that.
So, yeah,
that's been our selling point of
trying to get all of this
into our processes.
- Love that. Thank you. Q,
I see you had a question in
the chat. Want to jump in here?
AUDIENCE: Hi, yes. So my
background is in mathematics.
And I'm now moving
into bioscience.
So I'm currently doing my PhD.
And I'm going to finish
in a couple of years.
And industry just
seems like this massive
unknown, where, as an academic,
I don't really know
what is wanted.
Do you have any advice for
things to learn or technologies
to learn to make yourself
more competitive in that environment
and specifically in
bioscience? Sorry.
- Yeah.
I think--
I mean, now I can only really
speak from my own company.
I think there are, of course,
some technologies that
we're moving more towards.
So if you know
any of the open
source languages--
do you have--
I mean, recently, when
we have candidates,
we also look--
are they on GitHub? Like,
have they done something interesting?
Can they display a passion
for what they're doing?
And for us now, we're also
putting it in our job ads that
it's almost more important that you
are willing to learn new stuff.
Of course,
there are some jobs also in
the pharma industry where you have
to have a specific
degree to do that job.
But, for instance, for development jobs,
we're looking much
more into that.
Like, you have a
passion for doing it.
We can see that you
have done it before.
And when we speak with you,
you know your way around,
for instance,
package development and
which packages you use to do
package development.
And so I think it's a much more
now a display of interest.
So I think a lot of
companies today do these
interview
questions or
exercises that you do
before. And
like if you're applying at
a pharmaceutical company, then ask
about the disease that you're
maybe if you've gotten some
data on some disease.
Like, what does this mean?
Show that you're interested
in what it is that
they are trying to
do in pharma.
But keeping up with
technology is
a really good thing to
have on your resume.
- Thank you.
Rebecca, I see
you mentioned you
had a niche question.
But I feel like this could be
a good audience to throw that out
there too. So you
want to jump in here?
AUDIENCE: Oh,
you're super kind.
I wasn't going to try
to bug the whole group.
But I'm in search of someone
who has any experience with SAS
Viya and R interoperability.
Yeah, anyway, it's pretty
niche. So if it doesn't exist--
but in the conversation
of the agnostic Wild West,
I was curious if anyone
has that experience.
- Yeah,
unfortunately, we don't have SAS
Viya. I did see that you
also posted on
the pharmaverse--
AUDIENCE: Pharmaverse,
yeah, I'm sorry.
- --Slack, which is great.
No, no, I think it's great.
I do know some of the other
Danish pharmaceutical companies
use SAS Viya.
Maybe
I could try and get
somebody into that Slack channel to
share if they have
any experience with that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
would love that.
I'm coming from a mostly
SAS forward organization but as a
currently 100% R user and
trying to help people who want
to use both as my use case
since I think we've already
carved out the people who are
willing to already commit
to 100% R. I'm trying to
help those who want to
use both. So thank you.
I'm enjoying this a lot.
- You're welcome.
-
I want to jump back to the
conversation about packages for
a second here. I saw there
was a Slido question that said,
I'm curious from Ari's
experience of writing packages.
When would it be considered
overkill to create a package?
And when is it justified?
- Well, I mean,
it depends on whether--
so, of course,
now I'm sitting in an
organization where you know
that a lot of people are
doing the same exact thing but maybe
just a little bit
different than you are.
So most of the things that
we do every day is something that
at least 200 other
people are doing.
And that's really a strong rationale
for just making a package around
just working specifically with tables or
Git or repos and so on.
But if you're working for
yourself or in a small group--
like, my wife is a PhD
student currently and has also done a
small clinical trial.
And you kind of quickly learn
that you can actually gain so
much from setting up functions
for yourself to repeat tasks
over and over again,
to read in small data sets,
or to format something that
you want to output later on.
So I think there's probably not
a package too small if somebody
benefits from it and
especially yourself. But
in our case, it's pretty
easy to know when you're
supposed to do a
package. Most things--
and also kind of referring
to the comment before,
most things end up in a package
because we expect that many
people will use them, yeah.
- How would, Ari, actually--
helping share those packages
across the organization or
helping share what other people are
doing in different teams so work doesn't,
I guess, get duplicated? Do
you have community groups?
- Yeah. So one thing
that was running
and I think it's still running
is we had this initiative
called Radar, where
everybody could post ideas
to not just code
development but process development or,
like, let's get new coffee
in the coffee machine.
Or like whenever people start,
they should get a
water bottle now.
And so all these
different things.
In terms of code development,
moving into Azure DevOps
it's been a way for us to also,
first of all, make like
all of that work visible.
Before,
I couldn't necessarily see the
code and programs from another
drug project within Novo.
And we tried to really open up
and make all of that work visible
and kind of in a help
yourself way, where
if I want to see what
other people are doing,
I can just now see
all of their code.
And it's the same way with
the package development now.
All of that development
and organization of development is
also available for
everybody to see.
Yeah, so that's the way
we've done it. Yeah.
- Thank you.
George, I see you
had asked a question
a bit earlier about Shiny.
Do you want to jump in?
And I think the question was,
do you see--
let me just jump
back. I think it's,
do you see Python for Shiny
as something you would use for
your use case in
the future or now?
- I think
there will probably--
so I'm not that well
versed in Python.
But I can see--
I mean, there definitely
will be some use cases
for Python for us as well.
But a lot of the stuff
now, we have a huge SAS
infrastructure. And now we also
build a huge R infrastructure.
And now when we're
starting up with Python,
you have the
reticulate package.
And you have so much like
interoperability between R and
Python that there
might be many things
then where you either use the
plumber API or reticulate to
use the best thing of those
languages. So not even--
if you were to at some point in
the future do a full trial in Python,
you would maybe just call
some of the R infrastructure
underneath it because those two
languages are now so easy to
kind of switch between.
But
I love the quote I think--
and probably I saw Joe Cheng's keynote
again not too long ago about Shiny.
I think it was last year where
he says like Python was--
it's the second best
thing for everything.
And
it is really
when you're looking at doing
production-grade
enterprise level
apps or assistance that you build
both in R and Shiny and
also other technologies,
I think that
Python will be some of the
things. And that's also what we
recently hired for,
that we want to have
Python developers also to influence
some of the stuff that we're
doing in R that might be even
better to do in Python. So
it's definitely
coming, I would say.
- Thank you.
So a question that I
love to get to ask
leaders in this space is,
could you share an important
lesson that you've learned over
your career or maybe a career
lesson that just stands out to
you when I ask that?
- I think--
I mean, there are kind of
two things that come to mind. And
one of them is--
I mean, this is just my
kind of personal belief in
if you want to do new
fun stuff that you think will actually
help somebody at
work as well as--
I try to do this
rule where I have
no side projects
because
usually you're doing work.
And then you have this
side project that you're really
excited about that you want to
build up some stuff and so on.
But people know that the
actual work is really what consumes
all of your time--
so trying to
have no side
projects in the way.
Whereas if you have
a side project, you're trying--
I'm really trying
hard to make--
I'm like, this is actually
what I'm supposed to do,
like the same with this Shiny
app that we were trying to--
this is how the
process should be.
This is how we want
to work with it.
And also now rolling R,
we wanted to do more in R
development. And we can also see now that
we can interface to so
many different things that like--
but the people coming into,
especially my project,
if I've told them--
now we're running these
five trials. Everything is [INAUDIBLE].
And on the side, you'll have to
learn R because in two years' time,
we're going to do a trial in
R. So I've really tried to use my
power in that sense that I
really wanted to change their
environment such that it's not
a side project anymore. Like,
I want you to learn
this stuff on the job.
And we'll try our best
to kind of support you in
doing that because--
I mean, there's also some
psychological aspect of
working towards a deadline with
something you know will
be used by somebody.
So you try a little harder.
But it's also just like,
whoa, this is really new and
exciting. And there are
people here to help me do it.
And people just grow incredibly
fast if you let their
side projects be their
main projects really.
And another thing is like--
one of the things that
made the biggest splash in
terms of now we have some new
technology we could use is
it's not the Shiny apps. And
it's not like using R and
processes. I did this--
so whenever we have a trial
ending and there might be some
sensitive information or
confidential information that you
need to keep secret until
you kind of do a press
release with the results,
everybody who has access to those
data needs to be an insider list.
And what we previously done
is like the responsible
programmer. So the programmer
in my role kind of tracks
who has access to the data.
And then we generate a list
that we send to our legal
department. And then
they put them on inside.
So it's like this
long chain of--
and they--
up to when we do the
release and so on,
they're asking every
day, maybe twice a day,
for this list. Like, did
anybody go off of this?
Did anybody new
get access to the data?
And I remember, I
don't want to do
that every day.
I don't want to sit and figure
out who has access to the data.
And, luckily, with
R, we now had--
we could query
the server that we had data
on for accesses and just wrapped
that into a data table
in a markdown script,
put it on a connect server,
and then just made it open
for them and made it refresh itself
every six hours.
And
so many people who
maybe have some technical roles
that are not really touching
data in that sense--
you had so many people
now getting automatically on the
inside of the list that they
may not have been on before.
And there are so many people
outside of the area that I
have. And they were
like calling me. Like,
what is this thing
that I'm now on this?
And so listen--
and that's because
they want to do [INAUDIBLE]
about having
access to the data.
But it just creates such a huge
splash that now we were able to
automate this part of it. And
so many people were kind of
affected by something
that we have automated.
That has really like
resonated like far out into
our stakeholders
that we did that.
And I mean, we thought it was
pretty cool that so many people now
like automatically got on the
list. And that's been one of
the biggest lessons too.
We automated something, right?
That actually created
value for others.
So that was a
pretty cool. Yeah.
- I love that.
It's really cool when you get
to see all of that feedback
from everybody right away.
Like, just yesterday,
I did something really small
where I added like a download
CSV to a table that
was in a Quarto doc.
And I realized right away,
that made that report so
much more impactful to somebody that
they could download it.
Niels, I see you just put
a question here in the chat.
You want to jump in? And
I can read it. It is,
what is needed to submit
a Shiny app to a regulatory
agency? What are the requirements
that they are looking for?
- So I might not be the
best one to answer this one because
it's not something
we have done.
The only thing I know is
that the R consortium working
group ARPA submission has
some really great people working
on getting Shiny apps to FDA.
And there are many
aspects of that. Like,
how do you read the data into
a Shiny app in a system where you
don't know where the data is?
And how do you spin up
something that can run a Shiny app?
So there is an association for
statistical programmers
in pharma called Fuse,
which has had a
working group around
interactivity and submission
for quite a few years,
whether we're talking about--
if everybody is submitting Shiny
apps, like, FDA will never know.
There's no red
thread around, this is how
we do data imports in Shiny.
So if everybody is making
up their own UIs about
how you analyze data,
I think FDA will have a
hard time going through all of those Shiny
apps. So they've been working
a little bit on,
should we try and set
up some standards around
submitting something like a
Shiny app to FDA?
And I think even
less could even do it--
like, if you were doing
just like HTML file,
if you were using
flexdashboard to do stuff,
I think that could go a really
long way. And I do believe so.
FDA has a
file format
specification document
where all of the
allowed files--
and I'm pretty sure
dot HTML is on that one. So
you could get pretty far probably with
doing something in Quarto
or Markdown in that way, yeah.
- So maybe a big question to answer
in a few minutes here. But I see,
Jared, you had a question on
validation. If you want
to jump in and ask that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no,
this is just a kind of a
hot button topic that a lot of
groups are going into. But
just how did you guys
approach the issue of
dual independent programming and
validating your ADaM [INAUDIBLE]
and ADaM TLF data
sets? Was it more of a
one side used SAS,
another used R?
Or if you both used R when
it came to package and environment versioning
validation to
provide that full
traceability to the
[INAUDIBLE], how did you
guys approach that infrastructure
behind the scenes if you
don't mind me asking?
- Yeah.
So one of the things I think
I can mention first is that
for quite some years, we
have been working with our
standard operating
procedures and making them
more easy to work
under. And especially--
so we have one for--
we call it the custom
programming SOP,
Standard Operating Procedure,
where we talk about the
different revenue levels that we're applying
to custom programs
as we call them.
And there we
kind of introduced a
self review level, peer review
level, and then double
programming review level,
most people call it. And
we're actually trying to do
less and less
stable programming.
So
for many years,
we've kind of been--
had our ears blown full of
risk based approaches to many things.
And
so we've been trying to--
you double program the
really most essential parts--
primary analysis, the most
important analysis data sets.
And then if you step
one level out to--
most
people do double programming.
They have done it in SAS.
But most people are
doing it in R now.
We're also doing R versus R.
And then in terms of doing
those TFL in order to
encapsulate like what you're doing on
the trial, I mean, we're running
R-E-N-V, or renv,
to control like the
local environment.
And that's also why we need
it to have those trials.
We needed to add
them use give--
because we need to track
like that local environment.
And then
if you step one further out
into how are we getting
packages into the
organization--
I mean, we use a passive
package manager. And we apply
the risk based approach
from the R Validation Hub.
So we do risk
assessment of packages.
And we have worked--
or some of my very good
colleagues have worked very hard on
automating that to some sense.
I think if you want to
have a really good example
of how that would
look like is--
I think it's Aaron
Clark from Biogen
has created this risk
assessment app which is built
upon the risk metric package.
And we use that as
well for our internal
risk assessments. And then
the environment itself, like
the workbench and
the package manager,
we've had some people from IT
help to bring it up
to a GXP validated environment that
we can actually run trials in.
Yeah, I hope that covers it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think my biggest issue
I've encountered is just
trying to allow any sort of
confidential or patient
sensitive data into a GitHub or
even if it's a private repo
or something to allow that to be
moved out of some firewall
locked state. And so then comes
the question of--
SVN or what do you use
at a local level to ensure that
Docker or Kubernetes or what
to containerize the versioning as
well as the validation of
the packages and everything so that
it can be built from that?
And then it just becomes--
it just turns into this mess
of trying to explain and keep
separate. So if
that makes sense.
- Yeah, I mean, so
maybe, luckily, I can say-- I
mean, we don't use GitHub. So
we have Azure DevOps within the
firewall. And I think
one of our recent
GXP
requirements are that basically
any system that you're like
interacting with when you're doing trial
has to be within the firewall.
And in terms of this system--
so, of course,
there's a lot of documentation for
the system that you need to
have in place if somebody
were to inspect the system.
R system will soon--
I think actually tomorrow--
shift to run on Kubernetes.
It's been running on
like Amazon virtual
machines, I think, for now.
And everything there is built
infrastructure as code.
So we have control over everything
we do there. And as I mentioned,
the guys from IT are
really ones helping
with the requirements around
standing up that environment.
And they also have
inspection experience from other systems
that we have. So that's been a
huge help in kind of getting it
to work for us.
AUDIENCE: No, that's great. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
- Oh sorry, Jared.
Sorry if I cut you off.
But thank you so much,
everybody, for joining today.
And thank you, Ari, for sharing
your experience with us.
I wanted to remind everybody before
you log off if you want
to hear more about the work
they're doing at Novo Nordisk and
see Ari again presenting, that
event will be on September 12.
And I see Tyler just shared the
link in the chat right now if
you want to check it out.
But, Ari, thank you so
much for joining us today.
- Yeah, thank you so
much for having me.
It's been an honor to be here.
- If people want to
get connected with you,
is the best way LinkedIn?
- Yeah, probably on LinkedIn.
- OK,
awesome. Well, thank you all. Have
a great rest of the day.
Nice to see you.
- Yeah, thanks.
- Bye, everybody.
- Bye-bye.